hi I'm Maddie Jen we gotta go we got to
catch the sunset do you think we can
catch it what time is it now ah I think
we can make it yeah no I haven't opened
it yet I'm going to open it now yes okay
I'll shoot the video you take the dog
for a walk
this is great guess my friends is a
cannon a TD another one camera that is
pretty much used on my channel is the
Canon 70d but kind of like these types
of videos but I also end up using my set
of a camera which is back here for sort
of more the professional type videos and
for vlogging I use the g7 X or the g5 x
I'm gonna put yapping I'm gonna open
this up so I can take you guys outside
and for a test drive of it that the body
oh look at that body so as I said this
is the upgrade to the 70d what I'm kind
of excited about is trying out the
onboard audio right now I'm currently
using an external microphone which I
definitely will put on here as well but
I would love to see the comparison
between this one and the other one
because they now move the microphones
here into the front what should help out
a lot for not only being able to get
your voice of the subject in front of
you but also helping eliminate wind
about our battery charger the battery
that you use for the AED is the same as
the 70d which is fantastic because you
won't need to upgrade any types of
batteries the Sun set we're going to
miss the sunset okay and the new lens
this is the 18 to 135 now I've got a
bunch of the kit lenses that previously
come with the 70d and the t2i
so I was like oh you know what this time
I'm not gonna get the lens I'm just
gonna get the body then I did a little
bit of reading and this actually is the
EFS and this is an all new lens and it
has this little I'm not sure 100% what
it's called when I look it up later I
will put what it actually is called
right here so this lens is the EF
18-135 millimeter lens and it's a quick
tour this new type of focusing motor for
high speed autofocus and those sensors
that I'm showing you right here is will
allow you to use a power zoom adapter
which will only work with this newly
designed lens as Canon states in their
press release it's the world's first
attachable zoom adapter that will
provide a silent and smooth zoom I'm
doing air quotes but you can't see it
what I'm most excited about this is
you'll be able to control the zoom using
the Canon camera connect app which is
canons app that allows you to connect to
any of their cameras using Wi-Fi also
something cool to look forward to is the
first Canon branded external microphone
that should be at the end of June I did
actually just pre-ordered mine the one
that I'm currently using is a rode
microphone which I believe is actually
pronounced Ruud but I think most
youtubers just call it rode I'll put all
of the links in the description of
pretty much everything that I've talked
about and that I use I'll put this on in
the car
lens is heavy dude that's heavy holy
moly pretty sure this battery is not
charged no card in camera wow this lens
is nice heavy so here's the audio on the
ATD no microphone no nothing here's the
audio on the 70d with the rode
microphone so these are both pretty much
arm length apart hello this is a much
wider angle lens or as this is pretty
true to life let's take you to the
promenade let's go focus is nice
Justine Justine hi TMZ here we heard you
were coming 2:30 from rugby was good the
Cheesecake Factory can you confirm or
deny I confirm that I really want to go
the Cheesecake Factory no actually I
don't want to go to feedback to write
Justine Justine I hear you want tomato
soup can we confirm her tonight
confinement
I love sweet and soon they just need
Mobile Russian how do you feel about
frozen yogurt I love frozen yogurt if
you were topping cookie dough great
thank you
I could get a new job vlogging with a
DSLR is heavy
we're trying on shoes how's the lens
look
we're gonna miss the sunset because I'm
shopping for shoes
come on let's go
I get it
it's too cold for any more of a
time-lapse sorry
alright I'm gonna switch to the
wide-angle lens
Oh God I'll see what this looks like
this is why I don't invite you to come
shopping wow that's a lot lighter okay
there we go
back to the vlogging lens look at that
such a wide angle beautiful really nice
you tonight
don't nobody walk so fast so you hook
this bow
I just change the quality to a faster
frame rate what's it look like fast or
Nia
oh she just put the side over I look Oh
your math okay guys I hope you enjoyed
this random test out here in the u.s. a
TD
this may be the end the video may not be
if it is the end I love you I'll see you
later
don't you guys think